movie trailers in general are often
guilty of lying to us and it seems that
goes double for Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker trailers have made us believe
we're going to see a number of things
that probably won't happen here's a look
at some of the biggest mr. X one of the
most surprising shots and the rise of
Skywalker marketing comes from the
second trailer which was released at the
d23 Expo in August we're talking about
the shot of Rey in a hooded cloak
holding a lightsaber with two red beams
we've never seen a lightsaber like that
in a Star Wars movie so it's an
intriguing reveal on its own but then it
unfolds into a double-ended weapon
reminiscent of Darth Maul's
clearly this shot is meant to make you
wonder if Rey will follow up on our
darkside temptations and go evil for the
end of the trilogy but no one really
thinks that's going to happen right
especially after the marketing team for
the last Jedi did kind of the exact same
thing already
I don't believe that a couple
explanations come to mind the first is
that Rey is having a dream or vision
like Luke did during his visit to
Dagobah in the Empire Strikes Back
another possibility is that the dark
version of Rey is some kind of evil
clone we don't know for sure but it
seems the least likely option is that
the shining beacon of hope will turn
evil and stay that way in the final
installment of her trilogy also seen in
the second rise of Skywalker trailer is
a brief but curious shot of everyone's
trusty and perpetually anxious protocol
droid c-3po with conspicuously red eyes
the big implication here is that somehow
c-3po has been tampered with in some way
the droids red eyes are a first in his
skywalker saga arc and they seem to
imply that some entity has infiltrated
c-3po why else would they go red punch
three shooters c-3po red eyes seem like
a misdirect intended to mislead viewers
by encouraging them to think that the
Droid has turned to the dark side
is it a temporary malfunction maybe a
simple problem with some faulty wiring
our favorite golden droid isn't getting
any younger so it's not surprising that
he might need a tune-up or upgrade for
years on but the red eyes somehow
indicating c-3po is going to become a
tool for the dark side is probably one
idea we should definitely drop the final
trailer for the rise of Skywalker
features a shot of Rey and kylo Ren
fighting side-by-side considering that
plenty of other footage shows them
fighting each other it's tough to gauge
what the rise of Skywalker wants us to
believe about these characters we've
already seen Rey and kylo Ren work
together to defeat Snoke and his guards
in the last Jedi they've also shared a
connection through their force
sensitivities even communicating and
tracking one another's movements it
would be easy to think the Skywalker
saga was gearing up to make some
grandiose statement about finding and
embracing the gray area between the
light and dark sides of the force and
teaming up with your presumed enemy
against a far bigger threat on the other
hand Rey and kylo Ren returned to their
respective teams after defeating Snoke
in the last Jedi and remained enemies
through the end of the film by showing
us scenes of them fighting against and
alongside each other it's clear they
don't want us to know what actually
happens the big question that comes from
the shot of Rey and kylo Ren teaming up
in the trailer is why they're doing it
in the first place
is there a mutual recognition of their
power and capabilities are they really
teaming up or just trying to exploit
each other to keep all that a mystery
the marketing is trying to have it both
ways
Ray's back story has been a mystery for
Star Wars fans ever since episode 7
first came out years ago she's
essentially the main character of Star
Wars right now and we really don't know
a lot about her past or present other
than the fact that she's really really
good at using the force very few clues
have been dropped about her life before
we meet her in the force awakens to date
all we know is that she was abandoned on
the planet jakku which led her to a life
of scavenging believing she was nobody
through interrogations intense
conversations kylo
has frequently hinted that he knows the
truth about Rey's past including her
parents who were apparently no one
special
filthy junk traders who sold her for
drinking money you have no place in my
story you come from nothing you're
nothing
knowing this makes one particular moment
in the rise of Skywalker trailers all
the more intriguing during the final
trailer as they face off in the rain on
a piece of wreckage Rey is seen looking
at kylo Ren while her voiceover states
nobody knows me the camera cuts
revealing kylo Ren as he activates his
lightsaber and his voiceover replies but
I do putting these two shots and their
corresponding voiceover one after the
other in the final trailer certainly
implies kylo Ren will reveal Rey's past
or some other potentially
earth-shattering truth about her that
will change her direction in the rise of
Skywalker it's the kind of tease that
gives you deja vu
haven't we already dealt with this issue
was kylo lying before or are the
trailers lying now furthermore does
anyone even care who raised family is at
this point
it wasn't Luke it wasn't leia and it
wasn't han and it's probably not Lando
this late in the game would a big reveal
about her parentage even matter it's
probably Palpatine isn't it maybe that's
how we get evil Rey why not this is
where the fun begins check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Star Wars are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]